HAVE A GREAT NIGHT, EVERYBODY.
BE WELL.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
I KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS AND ON THE SHOW WE DO
OUR BEST TO DO THAT, THE MOST
TERRIFYING PERIOD OF THIS
EPIDEMIC APPEARS TO BE COMING TO
AN END IF NOT ALREADY OVER.
THE VIRUS OF COURSE WILL STILL
INFECT AND SICKEN AND KILL MANY
MORE AMERICANS, NOBODY SHOULD
MINIMIZE THAT BUT THE TIME FOR
PANIC IS NOW OVER.
AT OUR GREATEST FEAR GOING INTO
THIS WAS THAT OUR ENTIRE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WOULD
COLLAPSE UNDER THE STRAIN OF NEW
CASES.
THAT WAS A REAL FEAR AND IT WAS
JUSTIFIED.
THAT’S WHY WE LEFT THE COUNTRY
DOWN BUT THAT COLLAPSE NEVER
CAME AND WE WERE GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
THE FAMOUS CURVE THEY TOLD YOU
ABOUT HAS BEEN FLATTENED.
IN THE MEANTIME, AN AWFUL LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FLATTENED
THEMSELVES BADLY HURT BY OUR
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE, TENS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE HAVE LOST
THEIR LIVELIHOODS.
THE WHOLE ECONOMY IS IN TATTERS.
JUST TODAY, OIL FUTURES TRADED
AT NEGATIVE $40.
IN OTHER WORDS, THINGS ARE SO
SCREWED UP THAT PRODUCERS
COULDN’T GIVE IT AWAY.
KEEP IN MIND WE ARE NOT TALKING
ABOUT OVERPRICED HANDBAGS, THIS
IS PETROLEUM WHICH WE NEED TO
KEEP CIVILIZATION GOING.
THAT’S THE MEASUREMENT OF WHERE
WE ARE.
OUR ECONOMY HAS SHRUNK TO THAT
POINT, WHAT WE NEVER IMAGINED
WOULD BE POSSIBLE AND THAT’S NOT
A SMALL THING.
IT’S A DISASTER FOR ALL OF US.
SO GIVEN ALL OF THIS, IT’S NOT
SURPRISING AND IT’S NOT
UNREASONABLE THAT SOME PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO LOOSEN THE
LOCKDOWNS.
HUI FLATTEN THE CURVE, LET’S
FIGURE OUT HOW TO RESUME OUR
LIVES.
THAT DOES NOT SOUND CRAZY
BECAUSE IT’S NOT CRAZY UNLESS
YOU ARE THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
WITH THEIR BODYGUARDS IN THE
MEDIA IN WHICH CASE OPINIONS
LIKE THAT ARE A DANGEROUS THREAT
TO YOUR POWER AND MUST BE
STAMPED OUT IMMEDIATELY.
UNTIL RECENTLY FOR EXAMPLE, SOME
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN USING
SOCIAL MEDIA TO ORGANIZE
DEMONSTRATIONS AGAINST THE
SEVERE LOCKDOWN.
EXPRESSING YOUR VIEWS ABOUT THE
DECISIONS THAT POLITICIANS MAKE
IS PROTECTED UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTION.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT THE WHOLE
REASON WE HAVE A CONSTITUTION
AND THE FIRST PLACE IS LITERALLY
ENSHRINED IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT
AND FOR A REASON.
BUT FACEBOOK DOESN’T CARE,
FACEBOOK DOESN’T RECOGNIZE THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION, IT DOESN’T
RECOGNIZE HER CENTURIES OLD
NORMS.
THE CEO EXPLAINED ON ABC PEOPLE
WHO COMPLAIN ABOUT THE LOCKDOWN
AND ORGANIZE OTHERS TO DO THE
SAME HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
SITE FOR PROVIDING
"MISINFORMATION.
>> HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THE FACT
IT IS BEING USED TO ORGANIZE A
LOT OF THESE PROTESTS TO DEFY
SOCIAL DISTANCING GUIDELINES?
SOMEBODY TRYING TO ORGANIZE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, QUALIFIES
AS WRONGFUL INFORMATION.
>> WE DO CLASSIFY THAT AS
HARMFUL MISINFORMATION AND WE
TAKE THAT DOWN.
>> Tucker: MISINFORMATION.
THAT’S A TERM THAT SHOULD GIVE
YOU THE SHIVERS.
THE METS THE COUNTRY WE ARE
SUDDENLY LIVING IN.
THE STATE OF NEW JERSEY RECENTLY
ISSUED CRIMINAL CHARGES AGAINST
A WOMAN.
HER CRIME?
ORGANIZING A PROTEST AGAINST THE
LOCKDOWN.
IN OTHER WORDS, SHE CRITICIZED
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW JERSEY SO
HIS EMPLOYEES HAD HER ARRESTED.
ARE YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THAT?
ARE LEADERS APPLAUD IT.
MAKES LIFE EASIER WHEN YOUR
CRITIC SHUT UP AND GO TO JAIL.
THEY LIKE THAT.
IN NEW JERSEY, USING UNMANNED
DRONES TO SPY ON CITIZENS AND
MAKE CERTAIN THEY OBEY.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING THEY
DO IN CHINA AND THEY DO.
IN FACT, THE DRONES ARE
LITERALLY FROM CHINA.
I THE COMPANIES DONATED THEM TO
22 AMERICAN STATES TO CONTROL
UNRULY VOTERS.
SEEMS OBVIOUS THEY MUST BE
SENDING DATA BACK TO THEIR
MASTERS IN CHINA WHERE THE
PENTAGON BELIEVES THEY ARE.
BUT THE MAYOR OF ELIZABETH
DOESN’T CARE.
THE DRONES ARE HELPING HIM
CONSOLIDATE HIS POWER.
MAYOR BILL de BLASIO DOESN’T
SEEM TO HAVE DRONES JUST YET BUT
FOR NOW HE’S GOT THE NEXT BEST
THING, 8 MILLION POTENTIAL
SNITCHES ALL WORKING FOR HIM.
HE HAS ORDERED HIS CITIZENS TO
SPY ON THEIR NEIGHBORS AND
REPORT THEIR NEIGHBORS IF THEY
BEHAVE IN UNIMPROVED WAYS.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, IT SHOULD MAKE
YOU VERY NERVOUS WHEN
POLITICIANS LEVERAGE YOUR FEAR
TO MAKE THEMSELVES MORE POWERFUL
POWERFUL.
IT SHOULD TERRIFY YOU WHEN THEY
START ARRESTING PEOPLE FOR THE
CRIME OF DISAGREEING WITH THEM.
OUR MEDIA EXIST TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THESE KINDS OF
DANGEROUS.
ARE WE WATCHING THAT?
OUGHT TO BE ASKING THAT
QUESTION.
THEY SHOULD GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
IT, BUT THEY’RE NOT.
INSTEAD, THEY’RE CHEERING ON THE
OPPRESSION.
WATCH MSNBC EXPLAIN HOW ANYONE
WHO DISAGREES WITH THE
POLITICIANS THEY LIKE IT IS
NEEDLESS TO SAY A RACIST.
>> WHAT IS THAT THEY ARE TRYING
TO CHANNEL HERE?
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE PANDEMIC?
>> AMERICA FIRST WAS A PHRASE
THAT WAS FIRST USED BY CHARLES
LINDBERGH AND THE SYMPATHIZERS
IN 1939 1939 IN 1940 HIM IT BECA
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S RALLYING CRY.
YOU HAD THAT ON THE RIGHT.
>> WHEN I LOOK AT THESE, WHAT I
SEE YOU’RE A BUNCH OF WHITE
PEOPLE ESSENTIALLY SAYING IT’S
AFFECTING THOSE PEOPLE, SO WHY
DO I HAVE TO CHANGE MY LIFE FOR
THEM?
>> LET’S BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT
THEY ARE, THEY ARE THE FOX NEWS
CONFEDERATE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
>> IT IS NOT THAT HARD TO TURN A
HEALTH CRISIS INTO A RACIAL
ETHNIC CRISIS.
>> I THINK WHAT THEY’RE SAYING
QUITE CLEARLY WHEN YOU SEE THE
NUMBERS AND THE STATISTICS, I
WANT MORE BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
TO DIE.
IF YOU WANT THE GOVERNMENTS TO
OPEN UP, THEN YOU WANT MORE
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE TO DIE.
>> Tucker: JOY REID IS THE
BIGGEST RACE BAITER ON TV.
CAN YOU IMAGINE PUTTING THAT ON
YOUR TV IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
PANDEMIC?
ON THE BASIS OF ZERO EVIDENCE?
SO IRRESPONSIBLE, IT’S HARD TO
BELIEVE IT’S HAPPENED, BUT
HERE’S THE BIGGER THEME AND YOU
MAY BE SENSING IT.
CERTAIN PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO USE
THIS MOMENT TO ELEVATE
THEMSELVES AND CRUSH YOU.
ON THE VIEW TODAY, HOST JOY
BEHAR COMPLAINED THAT NOT ENOUGH
HAVE BEEN ABOLISHED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC.
EXERCISING RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS
SHOULD BE TREATED GOING FORWARD
IS A FELONY.
>> WHY ARE YOU BRINGING GUNS TO
A RALLY?
YOU CALL YOURSELVES PROTESTERS,
LEAVE YOUR GUNS HOMES.
THOSE ARE TERRORISTS WHO BRING
GUNS TO THINGS.
I DON’T TRUST THAT AT ALL.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE SHOULD
STAY OFF TELEVISION AND STILL
THEY CAN GET SOME CRITICAL
DISTANCE AND SOME WISDOM.
SOMETHING YOU ARE WATCHING HAS
BEEN UNLEASHED INSIDE MANY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO LEAVE THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS IN THE MEDIA MAKING
EXCUSES FOR FASCIST BEHAVIOR.
THIS IS THE MEDIA DEMANDING MORE
FASCISM NOW IMMEDIATELY.
THE SAD THING IS WHAT THEY COULD
BE DOING.
WE HAVE PROTESTS AGAINST
LOCKDOWNS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
YOU MAY LIKE THEM AND YOU MAY
NOT, BUT WHAT DOES THAT TELL
YOU?
WHY ARE THEY HAPPENING?
DID RUSH LIMBAUGH DO ALL THAT?
NO, HE DIDN’T.
AMERICANS HAD CONFIDENCE THAT
THE GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO
THIS VIRUS WAS WISE AND
THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGHLY ROOTED
IN SCIENCE, THEY PROBABLY
WOULDN’T BE FOR TESTING AGAINST
THOSE DECISIONS AND THE NUMBERS
THEY ARE BUT THEY DON’T BELIEVE
THAT AND THEY DON’T BELIEVE IT
FOR GOOD REASON.
WHEN THE STATE OF MICHIGAN BANS
JOINT REPLACEMENTS BUT
ENCOURAGES ABORTIONS AND LOTTO
TICKET SALES, NO EPIDEMIOLOGISTS
RECOMMENDED THAT FOR SOMETHING
ELSE BUT YOU WOULDN’T GUESS THAT
FROM WATCHING THOSE SHOWS ON
TELEVISION.
THE MEDIA ARE NOT BOTHERING TO
REPORT ON WHAT WE KNOW OR DON’T
KNOW ABOUT THE VIRUS.
IS FASCINATING BUT THEY ARE
IGNORING IT.
THEY ARE NOT EXPLAINING THE
SCIENCE OF WHY IT’S CLOSING
THOSE ALL SUMMER OR WHY IT
SCIENTIFICALLY REQUIRED TO TELL
CITIZENS TO SNITCH ON THEIR
NEIGHBORS.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN ADDRESSING
THAT.
INSTEAD THEY ARE LASHING OUT AT
THE INSOLENCE OF THEIR FELLOW
CITIZENS FOR FAILING TO SILENTLY
ACCEPT IT ALL.
MANY IN THE MEDIA SEEM TO BE
ENJOYING THIS CRISIS AND THEY
ARE.
IT’S BEEN A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
TALK AT GREAT LENGTH ABOUT THEIR
ALL-TIME FAVORITE SUBJECT WHICH
IS THEMSELVES AND HOW MUCH MORE
IMPRESSIVE THEY ARE THAN YOU.
IS THAT WEIRD LITTLE GUY ON CNN.
>> IT WASN’T UNTIL THIS FRIDAY
NIGHT THAT I HAD A WALL AND
THAT’S WHEN THE TEARS CAME.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO COMPARE THIS
WITH SOME IT CAN BE INCREDIBLY
ALARMING.
IT CAN BE INCREDIBLY DEPRESSING.
THE MEDIA CAN HELP.
MAKING MEDIA CAN HELP.
THE EMOTIONS ARE REAL FOR
EVERYBODY.
THEY WERE BIG PART OF THE STORY.
>> Tucker: OH, BARF.
THIS IS A GUY WHO GOT A SPECIAL
EXEMPTION TO THE GOVERNMENT
QUARANTINES HE SO FERVENTLY
SUPPORTS FOR OTHER PEOPLE, ALL
OF US IN THE MEDIA GOT THAT
EXEMPTION.
THIS IS A GUY WORKING A
HIGH-PAYING JOB WITH TENS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS NOT
WORKING.
PLEASE BE QUIET, YOUR TEARS ARE
NOT A BIG PART OF THE STORY AND
NEITHER ARE YOU.
FOR GOD’S SAKES, PLEASE STOP
TALKING ABOUT YOURSELF.
IS INSUFFERABLE.
BUT THEY CAN’T STOP.
THE MOST CONSISTENT BYPRODUCT OF
PRIVILEGE ALWAYS AND EVERYWHERE
IS NARCISSISM SO IT’S NOT
SURPRISING THAT OUR PAMPERED
OVERLORDS COULD NOT SHUT ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ DOESN’T
MAKE SENSE AS A PERSON.
OF COURSE SHE DID.
AND IT’S SO OBVIOUS ONCE YOU
KNOW IT.
THANK YOU, WIKIPEDIA.
AND SHE HAS A CHILD OF
PRIVILEGE, NOT SOME KID FROM THE
STREETS.
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY GREW UP IN
THE BRONX WOULD BE FAR TOO
EMBARRASSED TO DRONE ON ABOUT
HERSELF ON INSTAGRAM.
SUDDENLY PEOPLE SEEM TO HAVE A
LOT MORE POWER THAN THEY DID
BEFORE THIS PANDEMIC ARRIVED
FROM CHINA.
THAT’S AT LEAST AS SCARY AS THE
VIRUS ITSELF AND ITS EFFECTS
WILL LAST MUCH, MUCH LONGER.